hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I'm playing golf Recon wildlands at the
moment and wanted you to be aware of the
three ish cosmetic items vanity items
and a few useful guns too I'm bringing
this up due to the countless people keep
asking me how I unlock with the gap well
if you play the division and a few other
Ubisoft titles you should be aware of
the Ubisoft Club if that's new to you
then sign up now I definitely think it's
worth it you can access the club on
mobile PC or through the game itself
in-game simply pause and scroll down to
Ubisoft club it's a little hit and miss
at times but eventually you will load in
click on the rewards tab and feast your
eyes and all these goodies that you can
unlock here's what I mean about free ish
yes some of the items are indeed fully
free and no action except a simple
button press is required but some of
these they're free but have a lock
symbol on them basically Ubisoft wants
you to use the grocery contact force
website creating a profile joining a
task force following users and many of a
little minor inconveniences will lead
you to unlocking all this gear some of
the gear does require credit but don't
worry that's not coming out of your back
pocket that's obtained within the game
by completing missions and it can be
done in many other Ubisoft titles so if
you've been playing watchdog you may
already have enough credit to buy the
items that you want let's have a quick
look at my favorite the Tong edged
weapon camo changes the appearance of a
standard gun which i think looks damn
good especially on a sniper rifle
so this soldier is by the industry the
g36c is not the greatest gun in the
world but he's definitely useful during
the opening portion of the game there's
also a handful of costumes to unlock
which I'm expecting to grow in the
future so if you want to look like a
Yeti hunter you sure can
seriously got the future war gear set
looks awesome and check out the dying
earth cost you help me out here is this
a reference to Mad Max or maybe fallout
I'm a little bit uncertain what do you
think at the time of making this video
there are 21 items which can be unlocked
in the Ubisoft club but I fully expect
to see more costumes ranging from
Splinter Cell the division and maybe
even Assassin's Creed to Ubisoft have
already set a precedent to doing this if
you look back at the division there was
indeed a Splinter Cell set and these
since grade one was pretty cool too in
the meantime I'm going back to looking
like big box I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade there was a fair man throw this
up this way if this was useful see you
next time